bonjour barcadance bonjour moïse jambon
jose auditrices et auditeurs la
martinique la première vous êtes membre
du se-unsa c'est le syndicat des
syndicats de l'éducation nationale
vous êtes avec nous marque heden pense
que vous n'aimez pas du tout l'attitude
de l'académie votre syndic truer a écrit
au rectorat pour dire à pascal jean le
recteur que vous n'aimez pas sa façon de
travailler sa façon de prendre des
décisions dites nous tout nous sommes
sur la période et mouvement des
enseignants c'est à dire les changements
d'affectation et comme d'habitude comme
chaque année en amont de ceux de cette
période il y a eu un groupe de jeunes
travaillent sur ce qu'on appelle une
commission administrative paritaire pour
échanger sur les modalités d'affectation
des enseignants 7
cette circulaire ce ce groupe de travail
a mis en place une circulaire qui a été
validé par les oies président du
personnel que ceux de tous bords
également par l'administration et le
quinze jours après nous apprenons que le
recteur a donné des recommandations pour
faire autrement c'est dans ses
prérogatives au recteur de pouvoir faire
ça le recteur alors il a indiqué qu'il
avait reçu des consignes de alors cette
nous de nous dit on nous dit on qu'il a
reçu des consignes venant du ministère
et demandant de faire une autre façon
notamment pour le dispositif cp 100% de
réussite on va revenir à ce dispositif
qu'est ce qui vous gêne c'est que vous
avez proposé un certain nombre de choses
pour un certain nombre de collègues et
puis que brusquement
ben le recteur tout simplement vienne et
deux revers de mains balayent tout ça
ils décident de qui ira au seulement son
bon vouloir c'est ce que vous semblez
détester
entendons-nous bien il s'agit de des
femmes n'est un principe d'équité il
s'agit pas de favoriser tel ou tel
collègue s'agit bien de favoriser
l'équité de favoriser
l' équilibre pédagogique d'adam qui
existent au niveau des équipes
pédagogiques des écoles est également
une certaine harmonie n'oublions pas
qu'avant tout notre rôle à nous en tant
qu'enseignant c'est de former les élèves
qui nous sont confiées et autant qu
autant que faire se peut que ce soit
dans de bonnes conditions et dans
l'harmonie et là il a il provoque de
parler les choix qu'il fait il provoque
un total remaniement des équipes
pédagogiques voire même stress sur
l'ensemble des établissements scolaires
pour le premier degré c'est passé les
établissements scolaires qui sont une
éducation priorités en tête a dit allez
les ce qu'on appelle les l'ep irait plus
oui alors qu'est ce qui se passe
exactement vous défendez des peu des
personnes qui veulent juste préserver
leur petite zone de confort ou bien
c'est vraiment le mouvement de façon
globale et générale que vous dénoncez
nous dénonçons la gestion de du
dédoublement des classes de cp et de ce1
on va donner l'exemple bien concret
imaginons que je sois enseignante dans
une commune de martinique par exemple le
robert je peux tout simplement me voir
si notifié que je ne serai plus robert
l'année prochaine que je serai au voc
l'est au saint-esprit à ducos de façon
il ya trois ans que ça et que je
viendrais prendre la place de quelqu'un
d'autre qui pourrait rester là non pas
de ta vais vous ne serez peut-être pas
vous êtes au robert dans une école
indications prioritaires exemple hector
sainte-rose qui est une école en
éducation prioritaire et on vous informe
vous étiez sur le cp depuis 15 ans et on
vous informe que bombay à la prochaine
rentrée il n'y a aucune garantie que
vous soyez au cp sans que le directeur
lui-même ait eu la possibilité de
d'échanger avec vous saoule éventuel
sous votre éventuel choix d'aller sous
une autre classe là s'est imposé
d'office puisque le log l'organisation
choisie par le recteur pour dédoubler
les classes de cp ce et de fermer les
postes des derniers collègues arrivés et
de leur donner une priorité sur les
postes de cpe et le collègue est
actuellement sur la classe de cp n'a pas
d'autre choix que de prendre une autre
place de l'école ou ou éventuellement
éventuellement aller négocier quémander
un échange avec le collègue nouvellement
arrivées qui accepteraient d'échanger et
ce n'est pas toujours le cas
il nous semble essentiel qu'une
concertation soit fait avec les équipes
pédagogiques
c'est avant tout les équipes
pédagogiques qui peuvent déterminer qui
est à même d'être sous telle ou telle
classe et c'est dans ce cas là c'est pas
vous reconnaissez pas aux recteurs sa
capacité de pouvoir décider ce qui peut
être bon de façon sur l'ensemble sur
l'ensemble de l'île
nous estimons que le recteur a choisi
d'une méthode de travail autorités vous
dites vous dit aussi qu'il s'appuie sur
peut-être des documents de travail qui
date de certain nombre d'années oui je
suis dans lorsqu'on regarde la façon de
faire vous avez des collègues qui sont
leurs postes et fermé ils ont la
possibilité de participer aux opérations
du mouvement c'est à dire faire des
voeux prioritaire sur d'autres écoles et
puis vous en avez d'autres à côté il
dans les mêmes conditions le même type
de poste est fermé on leur dit avez-vous
vous est très affectée d'office ou tel
poste
ça ça ça date depuis il ya plus de dix
ans et c'est archaïque
justement nous sommes battus pour que ça
change il y avait des crispations à
l'époque et non nous voudrions pas
retrouvé ces crispations puisque le
collègue des collègues peuvent
participer en ayant des priorités et et
l'autre non il
il est en position neutre soit vous
demandez ccc l'équité nous demandons
équité de traitement de leur centre des
situations c'est pas le fait qu'on
puisse demander un collègue de parcourir
quelques kilomètres supplémentaires pour
se rendre sur son lieu de travail
on n'en est pas là on en n'est pas là il
n'y a pas eu bon qu'on lui doit
maintenant on ne sait pas on en n'est
pas là c'est nous dénonçons la méthode
qui a été utilisé il prévient ce
dispositif 100 % de réussite au ocp vous
en pensez-quoi dans le fond c'est une
bonne chose dans la france est une bonne
chose il s'agit d'apporter une aide aux
élèves les plus fragiles et de renforcer
les acquis les acquis fondamentaux écrit
à le lire compter pour nous c'est une
bonne chose c'est pas d'aujourd'hui
qu'il ya des dispositifs alors le
gouvernement précédent avait mis en
place les dispositifs
où c'était plus d'un mètre que deux
classes qui l'âge et à toute l'école
primaire
là c'est davantage on met l'accent
davantage sous les cp et les ce1
mais nous sommes globalement favorable à
cela c'est la méthode il y aura
suffisamment de postes pour tout le
monde
il y aura suffisamment n'a pas ce que
tout le monde non on va peut-être pas
très souvent du du premier degré ya
beaucoup de choses à dire dans ce
secteur de l'éducation nationale
rappelle que le premier degré ce sont
des écoles primaires oui voile et les
écoles primaires justement ce nom nous
si vous voulez c'est quand même le socle
de base
iris est une bonne scolarité passe par
une bonne une bonne scolarité à l'école
primaire
il n'y a pas de sujet qui fâche en ce
moment les directeurs sont heureux les
enseignants sont heureux tout le monde
est heureux la communauté scolaire de
façon globale générale des syndicats
sont heureux non nous sommes pas là pour
faire un polar crise que nous venons
d'aborder là ce sujet là qui est quand
même grave et nous n'allons pas lâcher
sur ce sujet et puis vous avez également
des des fonctionnements par exemple
aujourd'hui les directeurs d'école ont
qui jusqu'à aujourd'hui et l interface
entre les écoles et les enseignants
entre la hiérarchie et les enseignants
aujourd'hui il ya des moyens de
contournement jusqu'à un enseignant est
absent il a un document à remplir
il n'est plus obligé de le transmettre à
son directeur il pleut transmet
directement sa chance aux jeunes
ça gêne pour le beau le bon
fonctionnement des écoles un directeur
d'école il a organisé son école à
veiller à ce que à ce que tous les
élèves 3 en apprentissage effectif
et lorsqu'ils découvrent et souvent les
directeurs d'école ne sont pas sont
chargés de classe et il y est il a
besoin de savoir en tout cas avant
d'aller s'occuper de sa classe si tous
les élèves sont bien et sont corrects
sommes accueillis et là quand il n'a pas
l'information en amont il ne peut pas le
faire correctement
marc l'adn revenons sur ces ex contrats
aidés boulot ça vous vous en souvenez ce
sont des dossiers qui ont fait couler
pas mal d'encre il ya eu des mouvements
sociaux il ya eu des remous lorsqu'il
avait été question d'y mettre un terme
des accords d évaluation prévue avec le
préfet le rectorat trône est-il
justement justement nous arrivons sur un
sujet qui vous parler des difficultés
qui concerne toute l'école mais
particulièrement l'école primaire
puisque les contrats aidés les contrats
aidés aujourd'hui il est question de
changer le système si on parle de pe
c'est par où emploi compétences
alors dans ce nouveau système on va
mettre l'accent sur sur la formation en
finir avec le quantitatif on ira vers le
qualitatif
la philosophie est ce qu'il ya eu des
rencontres avec le rectorat avec la
préfecture sous les contrats mais juste
sur les tenues dans l'éducation
nationale en martinique nous sommes en
attente des rencontres étaient
programmées en fait aucune rencontre n'a
été faite par le préfet avec lui avait
prévu de nous rencontrer et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui nous sommes en attente hold
you lie le timing l'agenda précis des
rencontres il était censé nous
rencontrer en janvier nous sommes au
mois d'avril afin que je devais même
mais et nous amenons avons toujours pas
eu de rencontre et l'ajustement nous
avons écrit pour exiger ces grands
comptes puisque nous savons très bien
que si rien ne se passe là maintenant à
la prochaine rentrée nous serons en
difficulté une bombe à retardement
je nous espérons que le préfet entendre
aquila qu'il y a urgence sur le dossier
merci d'avoir été se bat avec nos
marques laden on rappelle que vous êtes
membre du syndicat se-unsa de
l'éducation nationale merci d'avoir été
sonate avec son caddie bonne journée
merci
[Musique]